hey this is Preston Walker reminding you
to mind your decisions in the following
circle chord a B is perpendicular to
chord C D these lengths are given the
question is what is the radius of the
circle I think a viewer from Edmonton
Canada for suggesting this problem it
originates in a junior math contest
around the 1970s can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution so how can we solve this
problem I'm going to present two
different ways one method will use
classical geometry and another will use
coordinate geometry so let's get started
with method 1 consider a circle that is
two perpendicular chords let's label
these four lengths as w x y and z what's
the radius of the circle there's a great
video on the channel math by amaya about
perpendicular chords and radius here's
the remarkable formula four times the
radius squared is equal to the sum of
the squares of these four values Wow
so let's use this formula to solve our
problem we're given three of the lengths
W is equal to 2x is equal to 6 and Z is
equal to 3 what's the value of y we can
solve for y using the power of a point
or the intersecting chords theorem W
times X is equal to Y times Z we can
then substitute in values and solve that
y is equal to 4 so we now have all 4
values and we can simply substitute them
into our formula and solve for the value
of the radius and we'll get the square
root of 65 all over 2 which is
approximately 4.03 1 wow that's a very
direct way to solve this problem but
what if you didn't know this formula
well let's actually prove why it works
the key principle is that a circle
Center is always along the perpendicular
bisector of a chord so let's start out
with the horizontal chord and draw its
perpendicular bisector let's label some
of these lengths now half of the chord
will be W plus X all over 2
the remaining segment will be X minus
this and that works out to be the
quantity X minus W all over 2 now let's
draw the perpendicular bisector of this
vertical chord it'll be something like
this
so now let's label some points first of
all this will be the center of the
circle because it's where the two
perpendicular bisectors meet next we
want to figure out this length and
that'll be half of the cord so it'll be
y plus Z all over 2 we now have the
necessary ingredients to solve for the
radius all we need is one more trick to
prove this we're going to draw this
triangle right here and it'll be a right
triangle because these two chords are
perpendicular to each other
furthermore notice that the hypotenuse
goes from the center of the circle to
the circumference of the circle so its
distance will be the radius of the
circle now we use the Pythagorean
theorem to get that the square of the
hypotenuse is equal to the summed
squares of its legs we can then expand
and simplify this formula now we use the
power of a point formula that W X is
equal to Y Z so we notice these two
terms cancel out so we then get that R
squared is equal to the sum of these
squares all over for all we need to do
is multiply by 4 and we get the formula
and that concludes the proof so now
let's go on to the second method that
uses coordinate geometry this is
actually the way that I solve the
problem because I didn't know that
earlier formula here's how I solved it I
set up a coordinate system where the two
chords intersect at the point 0 comma 0
we'll label the center of the circle as
the point P comma Q let's now label the
points a B and D a will be equal to
negative 2 0 V will be equal to 6 0 and
D will be equal to 0 negative 3 we're
now going to use these points and the
equation for a circle to get some
equations so from point A we're going to
get the equation that negative 2 minus P
the quantity squared plus Q squared is
equal to R squared we can then set up an
equation for the point B now using these
two equations
imagine subtracting them will cancel out
the Q squared and our squared terms we
can then very quickly solve that P is
equal to 2 we can then substitute this
back into one of the equations so we get
another equation that 4 squared plus Q
squared is equal to R squared we now get
an equation using point D we again use
that P is equal to 2 to simplify our
equation now using these two equations
we can subtract one from the other and
will eliminate the R squared term this
will allow us to solve that q is equal
to 0.5 we can then substitute that into
our first equation and we'll get 4
squared plus 0.5 squared is equal to R
squared we can then solve that r is
equal to the square root of 65 all over
2 which is approximately 4.0 3 1 so this
is another way that you could have
solved for the answer and I think both
methods are pretty cool thanks for
watching these math videos available for
free on YouTube build confidence for
students and inspire mathematical
discovery for viewers around the world
they have over a hundred million views
and the channel has over 1 million
subscribers if you like this video I'm
sure you'll enjoy my books please check
them out there listed in the video
description thanks for watching and
thanks for your support